when dissolved in water a strong base
like potassium hydroxide will dissociate
completely in solution to form hydroxide
ions potassium hydroxide is an example
of a group 1a metal hydroxide other
examples include lithium hydroxide and
sodium hydroxide
group 2a metal hydroxides are also
considered to be strong bases for
example calcium hydroxide is a group 2a
metal hydroxide and so is strontium
hydroxide let's do a problem with a
group 1a metal hydroxide sodium
hydroxide
let's say the ph of the solution is
13.00
and our goal is to calculate the initial
concentration of sodium hydroxide
first we write out the dissolution
equation solid sodium hydroxide
dissociates completely in water to form
sodium cations and hydroxide anions in
solution
looking at the balanced equation there's
a one in front of sodium hydroxide and a
one in front of hydroxide ions therefore
the concentration of hydroxide ions is
equal to the initial concentration of
sodium hydroxide
and we can find the concentration of
hydroxide ions in solution from the ph
at 25 degrees celsius the ph plus the
poh is equal to 14.00
so we can plug the ph into our equation
which gives us 13.00
plus the poh is equal to 14.00
so the poh of the solution is equal to
1.00
and the poh is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydroxide ions
so we can plug the poh into
this equation which gives us 1.00
is equal to the negative log of the
concentration of hydroxide ions
to solve for the concentration of
hydroxide ions in solution first we move
the negative sign to the left side which
gives us negative 1.00 is equal to the
log of the concentration of hydroxide
ions to get rid of the log we take 10 to
both sides
so the concentration of hydroxide ions
in this solution is equal to 10 to the
negative 1.00
which is equal to 0.10
molar
because sodium hydroxide is a strong
base that dissociates completely in
solution to form hydroxide ions if the
concentration of hydroxide ions in
solution is 0.10 molar so is the initial
concentration of sodium hydroxide
now let's do a problem with a group 2a
metal hydroxide let's say the initial
concentration of a solution of calcium
hydroxide is
.0010 molar and our goal is to find the
ph of the solution at 25 degrees celsius
calcium hydroxide is a strong base that
dissociates completely in solution to
form calcium 2 plus ions and hydroxide
anions
and looking at the mole ratios in this
dissolution equation there's a one in
front of calcium hydroxide a one in
front of calcium two plus and a two in
front of hydroxide ions
since the mole ratio of calcium
hydroxide to calcium is one to one if
the initial concentration of calcium
hydroxide is
.0010 molar that's also the
concentration of calcium ions so it's
0.0010 molar in solution
the mole ratio of calcium hydroxide to
hydroxide ions is one to two so if the
initial concentration of calcium
hydroxide is point zero zero one zero
molar the concentration of hydroxide
ions in solution is twice that
concentration so two times point zero
zero one zero molar is equal to point
zero zero two zero molar
now that we know the concentration of
hydroxide ions we can calculate the ph
of the solution one way to calculate the
ph is to first find the poh of the
solution and poh is equal to the
negative log of the concentration of
hydroxide ions
so we can plug in the concentration of
hydroxide ions into our equation which
gives us the poh of the solution is
equal to the negative log of point zero
zero two
zero and when you do the calculation the
poh is equal to 2.70
notice since we have two significant
figures for the concentration we need
two decimal places for rpoh
so to find the ph we know that ph plus
poh is equal to 14.00
at 25 degrees celsius so we can plug in
the poh of
2.70 and that gives us ph plus
2.70 is equal to 14.00
so the ph of the solution is equal to
11.30